[Music]
today I want to show you in my talk the
power and simplicity of sequel on top of
Apache flink and I also want to show you
why and how you can actually leverage
sequel for your use cases so SP said I
am team Walter working as a software
engineer at data artisans and part of
the thing team since the very early
beginnings so quickly about who is
actually data artisans so data artisans
is the company behind the pet chief link
we are still managing a lot of the
contributions we are also contributing
still a lot into Apache flink
we are it was founded by the original
creators of Apache flying and our main
product besides of services and training
and so on consulting is already data
artisans platform so we want to
commercialize a petri flink and make it
yeah make real-time stream processing
also Enterprise ready especially like
things like security and and other
things that are mostly relevant to
companies so if you want to try out our
platform there is a download a free
trial version that you can use for
trying data artisans platform basically
what data are essence platform is like
it's it's a possibility to manage your
streaming infrastructure especially if
you are in the streaming space it's very
important that your applications and
pipeline be around 24/7 if possible yeah
that is the code that goal at least and
yet data errors in flat film makes it
and makes those streaming applications
manageable so first of all before a
really deep dive into into sequel on top
of fling let me first also explain what
is actually a catch if link because I
mean many people have heard of it but
maybe not everyone is familiar with the
basic concepts behind the pet chief link
so first of all what are actually the
core
building looks so it doesn't matter if
it is a battery flink or not what are
the core building blocks for having a
stream processing pipeline so we
identified four different things that a
stream processor should be capable of so
first of all I mean we want to do stream
processing so we need data streams we
want to combine multiple streams we want
to do like ETL and multiple streams we
want to perform real-time computation on
streams we want to also be able to
replay streams in case of failures so
maybe there is a message queue or some
other stream storage system in front of
the stream processor then usually it you
do not only want to do the things like
ETL processing you also want to do like
more complex stuff so maybe you do some
machine learning so you need to store a
machine learning algorithm in state you
want to do you want to save the last
10,000 records in state so usually state
is also very important part of your
processing pipeline when we talk about
streaming we also have to talk about
time and especially about event time
because when when you work with
streaming data what you usually do is
you have some some time operations like
Windows you want to perform and one hour
window but when you do the actual
computation you maybe do not you don't
want to wait one hour until one hour is
processed you want to do this quickly
and this is possible you by using a
different notions of time like
processing time and fling and event time
and this also helps you to deal with
other problems related to screen
processing such as out of order data and
late data and also being able to replay
streams based on these times terms that
flink or other stream processors can
handle and the last and very the most
important part of every stream
processing pipeline is what happens if I
need to update my business logic what
happens if I need to upgrade the stream
processor or I just want to do some
testing and trying out new stuff what
you actually want to do is you want to
take a snapshot of your entire
screaming topology you maybe want to
fork off and use the snapshot in a
testing environment of staging cluster
you want to do versioning like trying
out your back fix before you go to
production and also maybe you want to
even do something like time traveling so
you take snapshots every week every day
and then you can play around with these
snapshots so if we look what is a
actually a stream processing
architecture we compare ourselves to the
classical tiered architecture so I think
most of you know this already like a
classical tiered architecture is split
up into usually two layers like you have
a computer you have stateless service
like web service for example and then
you have a database layer where you
store your data and then you have to
perform and read and writes this in
truth introduces latency this isn't
introduces throughput problems at some
point especially if you want to scale
out the computer layer you always have
to keep in mind how to a scale out
actually my my my database layer as well
and in the streaming architecture we
couple the computation and the state
very close to each other so the data in
the state are next to each other that
means modifications are local and we can
also scale out and scale in the
computation and state at the same time
so if we wanna if I would like to
explain the Patric think this is my most
favorite slide because it explains the
petrous link in just one animated
diagram so the link is basically how you
would define the data flow on a
whiteboard basically so you have some
operators like this bubbles here and
then you have some arrows that indicate
the data that is flowing through your
system and then you would do some
computation you maybe want to store some
events in state maybe you wait for an
ant event so you have to first store
them and then maybe you set a timer and
say okay maybe if there is no ant event
arriving maybe
after one hour I will too I will want to
process this event again and this is
exactly what aperture Inc is doing
so whenever a computation or an operator
is done with its copy with its
computation the results are immediately
streamed to the next operator you can
store events in state you can retrieve
them and you can also set timers at any
point in time and react on those timers
and this allows like more event-driven
applications and the very specialty
about think is we can do entire
snapshots of the running application
which is then stored on a persistent
storage and then you can recover from
failures or you can also perform cluster
migration and so on with these
persistent snapshots so to summarize
what is a patchy fling
you can summarize it in one sentence
like having stateful computations over
streams this is useful both for both
real-time and historical data as fast
it's scalable its fault tolerant think
has event time guarantees can handle
very large state in the orders of
terabyte and more and very strong
consistency guarantees so we provide
exactly once guarantee so no duplicate
or missing records through the
architecture of using a stream processor
we can connect ourselves to different
sources and things like the data can
come from applications from devices IOT
sensors and you can process both
real-time data streams and also
historical data that is stored like in
s3 for example after the flink
computation is done we can then also
dump our results into databases into
Kafka into files file systems yeah
depends on your use cases if you look at
the the users of fleeing so these are
the just a selection of some big users
where we know about uber is using Apache
fleeing in their streaming platform
I think it's called Athena X and they're
also using a lot of shreem sequel to
make it easier for their data scientists
and so on to define pipelines and also
for managing those pipelines in the
future Netflix is also using fleeing as
you can see in a very large scale the
Alibaba Group is one of our biggest
users of link so they are running
thousands of linked jobs and at very
very large scale so as you can see
100,000 cores and more but they are also
providing them stream sequel as a
platform and I envy a traditional bank
it's also using fleeing for more for
fraud detection of credit cards and
money transfers and so on
and yet the list is longer and longer so
as you can see a lot of companies like
lyft Airbnb Expedia who a ways they are
all ready I'm using flink in production
so but now let's take a let's talk a
little bit about link sequel because
that's our actual topic of this talk so
if you look at flings api's there we
have we have different levels of
abstractions so the data stream API is
our main API in fling it allows for both
batch and stream processing it has
okayish abstraction so the data stream
API provides some predefined operators
like Windows and dealing with data
streams in general you can use Galla you
can use Java for that if you like but we
also got the feedback that people
actually want to have more low-level
access to to fling and that's why we
came up with a process function process
function is a function that gives you
access to the primitives of a fling like
the primitives are having access to
events having access to State and also
having access
Lynx timer services so there you can
really deal with setting a timer
providing a callback what happens if the
timer fires and so on and this enables
you to build like real stateful
event-driven applications but we also
saw people having problems with Java
because not everyone is able to program
Java or Scala and we wanted to improve
that and that's why we put a sequel and
table API on top of the data stream API
and by the way you can mix and match all
these api's together so you can for
example use sequel for doing some some
pre-processing or some use some built-in
functions then you can go to data stream
or even to process function if you want
to do more complex stuff that is not
easily expressible by a by a sequel so
whatever you want to use there is an API
that maybe helps you in dealing with
with the problem let's talk a little bit
about links a pepper tree flings
relational api's so as I already said
there is the sequel API the sequel API
is plain sequel so standard sequel we
are not using some dialect of sequel and
in implement our own claw mmm sequel
clauses no this is standard sequel you
can copy every sequel query and paste it
also into a database and it should run
next to sequel we also provide a moral
programming like API so we are calling
this the table API table API is useful
especially if you want to integrate a
sequel program into your into your
bigger pipeline because it also helps
like identifying problems like the IDE
helps you when you design a pipeline
because certain operations are just not
supported at certain points when you
press the dot button
the key and you also get I mean you can
open the methods to get javadocs and so
on that helps while you are developing
pipeline so those two things doing
exactly the same thing but yeah you can
use either strings and one plane sequel
string or you do it in a more linked
style of fashion a very very important
thing is that we also try to both unify
better and streaming with those api's so
it doesn't matter if you run both of
those API queries on batch data or on
streaming data our goal is that a query
specifies exactly the same semantics and
the same results for for a given input
so how do we actually do that so this is
just a quick overview of the internals
how Flinx sequel api looks underneath so
as you can see on the left and on the
right side we have a table API and the
sequel API both api's have validation
and parsing layers in the core of our
API we are using the Apache calcite
framework calcite is Patrick Project
specialized for doing like relational
optimization relational planning and so
on so we are relying a lot of load on
also on the Patrick health side you as a
user you can register external tables
you can register data stream programs or
data set programs in Cal sales catalog
and then we insert rules to compile your
query down either into the batch part or
in the streaming part so dataset API is
the best part of Apache fling if you
have not know that
yeah because link is also the stream
processors also a very nice batch
processor and yeah you
can run batteries on fitting as well
if the data is bounded and if the data
is unbounded then we compile compile it
into a data stream program so let me
quickly I have explained how do we
actually ensure that we have the same
results for both batch and streaming
data so if you let's pretend we have a
clicks file it is it contains some your
l clicks from some users and we now want
to just count the number of clicks per
user I mean if we are in a in a database
or in a batch world what we usually do
is we read the entire the entire the
entire input at once we perform some
calculation so we put it into our queer
in our processor and in the end we omit
the result so the input is read once and
then the output is also produced just
once that's how the batch world works
how does it look like in the industry
main case so usually the records are
coming in row by row so what happens is
yes at first our stream is empty our
table is empty then we would insert a
row we were internally maintain some
counter instance link-state and then we
would omit like in this case a counter
of one that's straightforward right yeah
then Bob comes in also no problem we
will omit a counter of Bob afterwards
but then we have a problem because Mary
is there a second time so what happens
is we have to update our results so the
result that we sent out like Mary is one
becomes now Mary true so we have to deal
with with changes like we are omitting
changed looks basically and need to
update the results in the outside world
data is still SS read continuously but
the the output is updated also
continuously but as you can see the
final result of
both computations batch and streaming is
the same so why is actually stream and
better unification so important so first
of all I already mentioned that we
didn't want we did not want to provide
some custom sequel syntax and we don't
want to have stream specific results no
we want to be as close or identical to
regular sequel semantics and this is
also useful for portability because then
you can decide how you want to process
your data with sequel like in this case
in this example shows the data that is
coming in into your into your company I
mean if you want to run and clear you
unbounded unbounded data this is very
easy because you just cut the data that
is coming in into chunks like daily or
nightly batch job that you execute but
the nice thing is in streaming you can
decide when you when you want to execute
your streaming query so you can compute
it you can compute results from the past
but you can also start now and compute
to the future basically so you can have
running queries that start an at an
arbitrary arbitrary position in time and
then you can use the query either for
batch or for stream processing for
historical and production real-time
processing with the same semantics
actually this is not a very new feature
because database systems were doing that
for a very long time maybe some of you
have heard of materialized views so what
are materialized views like materials
views are a special case of view so you
define your sequel query in advance and
then the database system maintains
internally some table by consuming the
changelog streams of the base table so
usually a materialized view has no
access to the base tables but it just
consumes the changed look of those base
tables and materialized views are
usually you
to speed up the query time so that you
don't have to have to calculate the
query when it is executed for the first
time or accessed for the first time so
the database system already pre computes
the results for you and there you also
have have to deal with with changed
locks and that's why it is very similar
to how a Pesci flings sequel works
underneath so our core concept in a
fling is what we call dynamic tables
just to mention it
dynamic tables are just a concept so
whenever you hear like when we are
talking about tables in Fling there is
no table stored in memory or something
we only store in in fling state what is
really necessary to maintain a query so
you define a sequel query and this query
consumes data and emits data and this is
what a dynamic table does as well so a
dynamic table is not static it's it
changes over time the result of a
dynamic table is another dynamic table
so you can have sub queries accessing
another table and so on so you can have
a very complex pipeline and dynamic
tables never never terminate so they are
yep in the legging stream processing as
long as the input is unbounded also the
result stream the result output change
lock is unbounded and then it comes a
little bit there's a little difficulty
in how do you actually convert between
the stream and a dynamic table so the
there are basically three different
kinds how you can convert a stream to a
dynamic table and also how you can
convert it backwards so we name these
three types of conversion depend
conversion absolute conversion and
retract conversion which means append
convergence means that the changelog
stream that is coming out of the dynamic
table if you want to say like that
consists only of insertions so this is a
typical ETL use case where you just do
some projections so you maybe you want
to filter out some
feel that you want to apply some some
simple functions like x m conversion or
something like that so every every
insertion is also an insertion in the
result stream but what happens if you
have to update your results because like
in this example you wanna count and this
count increases and changes when your
records are coming in so there are two
types of conversion for changing the
results first of all if there is a key
defined then it's that is nice because
then we can use this unique key I mean
you can also be a composite key if you
want we can use this key for delegating
it to some to some system like please
update this key for me or please delete
this key for me this could be for
example if you want to store a dynamic
table in elasticsearch then you would
send some absurd and delete requests to
elasticsearch if the system or the query
does not support or does not have a
unique key attribute then we provide
another another possibility which we
call redirect conversions which means
instead of sending an absolute absurd
message to the downstream system we are
basically first deleting the old records
so we are deleting the record with the
old count and then we are sending it out
another record for inserting the new row
with a new count so every update is then
first of the légion and then an
insertion and with up up the absurd
conversions it would be just just one
absurd or delete now these are the the
ways how you can convert streams and
tables back and forth so let me also
talk a bit a little bit about what we
actually can do with links equal so by
by the latest version we have a lot of
built-in operators like you can do a
simple select from where queries you can
do group by you can use having for group
by week
we support both non-windows and also
windowed computations so you can also
define windows of one our using a
special or provided user-defined
functions that describe your window like
the tumblr windows hop windows and
session windows we provide different
joint implementations you can do it
non windowed like we know it from the
from the sequel world so you can use
regular inner left out and full joins if
you want to bound the state size because
for joins you never know if there is
another matching record coming in so
what you usually want to do you want a
window the computation a little bit so
[Music]
what we provide is that we have inner
joins left joins right and full auto
joints also in a windowed fashion where
you specify some some time constraints
in the where Clause basically for
streaming so so all these operators are
supported for both batch and streaming
and we also have streaming only
operations like the regular sequel / /
windows where you can look at the
surrounding of a row like whatever so in
your a creation you include rows that
were proceeding or bounded preceding the
the current row and we also support like
batch only operations maybe they will
also be supported in streaming in the
future but for now they are batch only
like Union intersect accept and also
order by especially for ETL and little
data pre-processing we have support for
pod rows so you can have arbitrarily
nested data we support also complex
types like maps and arrays and other
nested types we provide a large set of
built-in functions
like you like and extract time stem
functions and so on hashing functions
yeah this is I mean this is a continuous
effort you cannot support all the
functions because it's just too much but
we already provide provide 150 plus
functions and if there is a function
missing for you there is always a way of
defining your custom UDF's either for
aggregation functions for table valued
functions or for simple scholar
functions so there's also a point for
extensibility and you can also find more
about that in our documentation there is
also a large set of upcoming sequel
features like we want to improve the way
we can join data especially for
streaming so we're working on a
streaming enrichment showing where you
have or also called temporal join where
you can have a table that is
continuously updating and then you just
want to stream buy some records like for
example you have a currency table and
the current the current currency rate is
updating from time to time and whenever
order streams buy you wanna have a view
on this version table how did the table
look like at timestamp T because this is
the so for example I'm using the the
timestamp of the order I want to look up
what was the current currency rate for
euro to dollar currency conversion for
example we also want to support complex
event processing this is a very new
addition to the standard it's called
Metro recognizer
so we want to be able to define patterns
and in able to define patterns in
streams by using this clause so we
already provide a complex event
processing library in flaying and this
new mesh recognizer Clause allows us to
connect the already existing CP library
with our sequel library and define
everything in sequel if this is
necessary and we are also trying to
improve more on the connector and format
side because there are so many
connectors out there and
yeah people want to use fleeing the core
is very good but yeah maybe the
connectors need a little bit more law so
what can I actually build with all of
that I mean I already mentioned ETL so
you can define complex data pipelines or
you can transform things you can
aggregate things and move just the
events in real time from system a to a
system B you can do low latency ETL
which means yeah you can process the
data as it comes in and directly stored
in its final final location how you
prefer database system key value stores
Cassandra and elasticsearch and so on
you can perform stream and batch
analytics so you're defining define an
analytical query then you save the
results in elasticsearch and maybe you
add Habana on top of it and then you
have your dashboard ready when i'm there
so there are different possibilities to
use a stream processor for building
arbitrary pipelines this all sounds
great but actually how can I really use
it so where do i define my sequel
queries so I already mentioned that
usually what most people do is they use
this so they define their sequel query
they embed it in some bigger pipeline
that is developed in Java or Scala and
then they can also use other libraries
like I mentioned CP and we also have a
graph library yes so that you can also
package and operate your theory and your
entire pipeline and jar file and then
you can submit it to the flink cluster
this is the regular production ready way
of using things evil or that there are
many people are using but we're also
working on a new type of submission mode
because since link 1/5 is also possible
to submit sequel queries using a sequel
seal i client you can either use the
sequel client force
interactive queries or also for running
a detailed query - fleeing so we just
submit the query to fling and then yeah
then plink that's the the whole work for
you so you can shut down the sepal CLI
client so I quickly want to show you the
sequel client this is how it looks like
I will also show you a demo shortly what
is the goal of the sequel client goal is
controlling fling submitting your
queries without a single line of code
you define some properties in Yama and
you can drag and drop your sequel jars
for connectors and formats into the
sequel client and then you can either
either use the secure client for
prototyping or for submission so this is
how a regular yam will form it looks
like so you define the schema of the
table the sources like Kafka or
elasticsearch and so on and then you're
done basically and this is how the
architecture of the sequel client looks
like so you're submitting your query via
the CLI and then there is a gateway that
optimizes everything knows about all
available tables and then submits the
job to fling then flink runs the query
and for playing around with thing it's
possible to stream back the results from
the flink cluster to the Gateway and
then through the C light back to the
user but there's also as I said a way of
you can define your target table
basically using an insert into statement
in sequel so you submit the query and
then the Gateway takes care of
submitting and to fling then the flink
job runs and all the information you get
is like where where has the job been
submitted to so what is the cluster and
the drop ID and then you can go to the
the web UI off link and monitor your job
there so you can shut down the sequel
client yeah and that's basically it so
yeah specifying an insert into the to
specify the target specifying your fury
Connect maybe cough can elastic search
and your dashboard is basically ready
and this is also what I want to show you
now by the way
because we are also running out of time
at some point I won't show you I am all
the possibilities with sequel Klein and
fling sequel but if you are interested
in in this whole sequel area we just
created a sequel training that is
available publicly so you can have like
a little tutorial how to get started we
provide a ready to use docker comp
container that already AM has Kafka on
elasticsearch included so you can just
start this docker container and you have
to running for the instance to play
around with with things people so I will
start the docker compose container I
hope everything works with a with the
projector
so far we cannot see much great okay so
I will start the sequel client and the
background there is some Python script
that inserts records a little bit slowly
into Kafka and then we are reading from
Kafka so you can first show all the
tables we have right now so there is a
taxi right table and there are also some
things so the taxi rise is using the the
New York City Taxi right data set we can
quickly describe the schema of this taxi
rides yes you can see we have events
coming in describing a taxi start and a
taxi end event and yeah you can do some
computation on this on this taxi right
data set so I mean the first and most
easiest thing is just we're not just
printing the the data on the console as
you can see here's the data it's coming
in and so we are submitting a flink job
to the cluster yeah we can also reduce
the the refresh interval so now we can
look at our data we can select rows we
can open a row have a look and into our
our data and yeah so you can go through
your data if you want yeah why not also
performing some more batch like
computation with some statistics let's
calculate maybe the average amount of
passengers that attacks usually
transports and since we are doing this
in a streaming fashion we get into
immediately results like as you can see
we already process 7,000 taxi rides and
interestingly the average amount of
passengers per taxi is always one not
various protective spectacular but at
least now we know okay maybe you don't
have to pass our and our entire data for
computation because apparently
already converge to one so we can
already cancel this fury at this point
yeah this was some some more complicated
stuff
I hope the Beamer works yeah so this is
a sequel query that uses the built-in
window functions that we provide in
flaying here we just want to identify
very popular pickup and drop off
locations in New York City so what we
are doing with this query is basically
we compute every five minutes for each
area the number of departing and
arriving taxis so what we do is we are
grouping by the area ID and by the start
event and then we are defining a window
of five minutes and then we do some
computation so we are counting here and
yeah we also want to have the end
timestamp of this window I can also show
it quickly on the CLI
as you can see it's running and we are
getting our accounts and these accounts
can then be stored in Kafka again
because it does not contain any update
whenever a window is computed this is
insert only operation so we can dump it
into Kafka for example we can also do
more complicated in more complicated
stuff like yeah why not computing the
average right duration per pickup
location so what we are basically doing
is this query we have two sub queries
the sub query one gives us the start
events sub query two gives us the end
events that are coming in from the taxi
so we are joining these two events
together in order to bound this data
size we are using a window join here so
we are defining a time constraint when
these two start and end event should
meet meet each other so here we say okay
they should meet each other within one
hour that is regularly more than enough
for us yeah then we can group bys maybe
some some area ID and compute the
average here and we are doing some
transformation to convert it into
minutes in this example yeah and
and if you just wanna maybe you have
some computation and now you want to
just dump it into elasticsearch we can
also do that so let's just take a very
simple query so we it's a simple count
for area ID yeah let's look into our
elastic search so far as you can see
there is an index not found exception so
the index has not been created but once
we submit our query and say we want to
insert it into a predefined elastic
search sink once we submit this to the
cluster we can also monitor it in flink
so here you can see there is a running
flink job that executes our our pipeline
and if we go into elastic search we can
also see that now we have a swimming
pool iron and this count is updated from
time to time where it should at least
update itself
I don't know wise yeah so as you can see
that the count is increasing whenever i
refresh so our a pipeline you know it's
ready to use so just connect it with
some visualisation tool and then
basically you're done so as a summary
this whole unification of better'n
streaming is important because it in it
it makes architectures easier it also
allows you to have the same logic for
both types of queries or for both
historical queries and also for future
running long running queries things
equal already solves many many streaming
and best use cases and we are still
improving and improving to make the the
whole thing even more useful it's
already proven at scale at Alibaba at
uber also who a way is using fling
people in their cloud offering right now
you can deploy your queries either as an
entire fling
that is packaged into a jar and
submitted to the cluster you can also
use the CLI and we will also we are also
thinking about providing things like a
REST API so that you can just submit the
sequel query by a rest with a sequel
client yeah and then control fling from
this REST API by a sequel but for now I
would just invite you to join the
discussions because it's an open source
project and we are also very happy about
feedback how we can improve what is
missing and fling sequel so if you have
any valuable information for us or just
want to open a back report then do that
we are very happy about that if you want
to know more about fling there is also
there are two books so one book that is
covering the basics of fling and there
is also a very good and entire book in
the making that covers everything so
from the from deployment over API
considerations and so on it's not done
yet but some chapters are already
available on a Riley early release if
you're interested into Apache fleeing
and yes always we are hiring so if you
want to work with people on interesting
streaming stuff feel free to reach out
to me otherwise I'm waiting for you in
the office hour after this talk thank
you very much
[Applause]
so what kind of use cases would you say
are more favorable for fling sequel over
for example sparks equal variety of use
cases I would say like if you want to do
like simple ETL this is very useful
especially if you just want to map data
from one format to the other format very
useful drop and as I said like powering
dashboards like yeah if you have
multiple dashboards for different people
and you just want to specify this
dashboard as one sequel query that you
can manage and I mean a sequel query is
very easily manageable because it won't
change in the next 20 years I think
because it hasn't changed for the last
40 years so yeah that's that's one of
the use case whenever you want to have a
pipeline quickly entered by somebody
else maybe that is not familiar with
Java and Scala
you